[Music]
in moody decision news submitted by hi
my name is dot dot dot researchers
determine whose companies nikki loves
having ms oh that's why okay what if he
was a fan of JK news and he was
submitting issues like I would lose my
[ __ ] right he's all bored in his mansion
like I'm less of it this article JK news
is actually what's getting him through
it
every single day yeah you I couldn't
relate hard researchers determine whose
company we actually seek out when we're
happy or unhappy Oh what again sounds
like uh something we were just talking
about oh yeah you were miserable people
like misery loves kind of my dog perfect
my cat knows when I've been crying all
day and he just comes and finds me and /
super loud on my end like he like sits
right here on my heart and just like
he's like he just goes like this no he
doesn't eat really like I put them food
for him sometimes cuz he's just meowing
at me and he just wants my attention he
eats the faucet like he gets a medal he
eats my phone but he won't eat food why
me maybe has a vitamin deficiency or
some [ __ ] he's like you tip I think he
had the trouble with food and like he'll
he'll just eat a little bit and then
he'll be like I'm good yeah yeah that's
why you look like a cat yeah maybe I
should use your tricks to get him over
it what's my trick just to get more
confident like just I don't know what
you do tell me he got his birth control
yeah that's exactly what made me start
eating normal is taking out my birth
control alright so this story here has
nothing to do with this take out his
birth control so all right so these
researchers they've looked at social
interactions and moods of more than
30,000 people by using this app called
58 seconds which would text participants
at various times of the day and ask them
to type in how they were feeling what
they were doing and who they were with
if they were with anyone horny sex
girlfriend Barney sex
mistress
yeah I like you're texting like me word
sex mistress it's a drumstick yeah it's
a drum yeah so what they found out is
that people who are in a happier mood
they tend to and this is obviously not
for everyone is just that they're
looking at just correlations here not
causation so they're saying that when
people were in a happier mood they were
more likely to interact with strangers
and then after that stranger interaction
for whatever reason like they'll end up
not feeling as happy and then they'll
seek out people that they know it's so
like family or friends and that's just
the just to summarize this whole article
and the other way around too they're
saying like if people were kind of sad
mm-hmm they naturally go seek our family
oh so it's like so people that you know
is when you need to be happy but the
once you get to a certain level of
happiness it's like [ __ ] this place I'm
hanging up my best friend tomorrow and
then you get happy again let's go
clubbing tonight and it just keep going
like this hmm
yeah huh what summarize this whole thing
what is a stranger what's considered a
stranger
someone that doesn't to give you there
really a stranger in the end we're all
connected somehow
people are strange like if you end up
having like meeting someone at the bank
or something like you end up having
those like small talk and when you don't
know it all
yeah not just colleagues but like you
guys ever talk to strangers it didn't
halfway through the conversation you're
like you're a loser for talking to me
like why would you even talk to me yeah
like yeah like I was hiking the other
day and then this guy was like we were
just talking about oh my god because
Maddie went up and like wanted it you
should say his name now
I forgot I didn't even ask his name
because I avoided that [ __ ] but then he
wanted to get Matty wanted basic she
wanted affection right so then she just
does this to [ __ ] strangers and until
he was like oh my god they didn't
[ __ ] being all nice to the dog and
I'm like all right cool get out of here
in my head I'm thinking get out of here
right and he's like so uh what other
good hikes are there in California yeah
I'm not from California I'm from this
and that and I can
help myself cuz I'm having a good
conversation because I'm bored too and
then halfway through the conversation
I'm like you have no friends
why are you by yourself yeah and I'm
like I'm not either I know that's why I
judged him cuz I'm all like if you're
rejected your own things it's a
reflection of how you feelin yeah I'm
like I wanna [ __ ] peacefully walk here
because I know what's gonna happen
toward the end of this hike you're gonna
be there you're gonna want to talk to me
again and that's what happened I
predicted that [ __ ] but I also did start
talking to him first so when I got there
see I told you the waterfalls this way
cuz he was lost and he didn't know which
way the waterfall was so I was like see
I told you the waterfall is here and I'm
like [ __ ] I trapped myself some people
with a lack of social awareness that can
be awkward to try and peace out but when
I went to a university that was in a
smaller town
I actually was surprised at how friendly
people were where I'd be any scares you
right I don't like it
I was at the bus stop and someone said
like hey how you doing I'm like excuse
me and they start talking to you and
they actually want to know but you kind
of get a funny vibe sometimes such as in
Texas people are friendly but they'll
say like hey how y'all doing or like
what do you have - I'm like what why do
you want to know you know like it so I
think when they said strangers when
you're actually happy you seek out more
strangers you think Canadians are
friendlier or Texans
I think Canadians all I'm not friendly I
think so - cuz I was in the hotel in
Toronto yeah and I was on the first
floor right it stops at the second floor
these four Canadian guys come inside and
they looked at me and I'm just like like
this annoy oh hey how's it going now and
they'll introduce themselves and I'm
like I'm not gonna see you after two
more floors ever in my entire life and I
had to introduce myself to four do they
do they waste a lot of time in Toronto
so pretty pretty normal Joe yeah which
is why when I went to a smaller town
where it's even friendlier it's like the
next level I don't know what's even
friendlier they just get naked and
they're like let's do it I'll give you
an example over for dinner I think I was
on the bus and there is a lady next to
me
was drunk and she like fell completely
asleep I needed to get off at that stop
and she was a larger lady I ride the bus
I was 18 oh there's no ride the bus but
what I was gonna say is it was hard to
you know hop over her and I couldn't I
was tapping her but she was the jungle
gym handles so it was over her so you
know it's like it's to the left and so
it's over but the people in front of me
they helped coordinate so you need to
get out they both got out of their seat
one that gave me their hand no I just
got like that that's the level of
friendliness video experience which
actually is pretty cool oh yeah in some
situations but you know when you're not
ready like you don't feel like talking
to a stranger and then they approach you
that it's me 24/7 thank you dude that's
never been me but recently heat when we
were at the spa and then that that girl
did you cuz he started striking up a
conversation with us I thought she was
like really cool in the beginning of the
conversation but then like she just kept
going and you know yeah like she wanted
to be her friend and I was just like
that's what I'm talking about and you
were judging her like she's a [ __ ]
loser
no she yes yeah yeah don't get them in
the middle don't you judging her I was
like yeah I was like we're [ __ ] cool
I get it but we don't want you in a
circle you're naked in that Spa like
it's different no try not okay you know
exactly how you fell much no we're not
people this [ __ ] like you Joe is trying
to recruit us into your [ __ ] team no
because that you doesn't feel like her
right I used to be like talkative all
the time but not as much as shoot so she
kind of like passed the thresholds of
what I would be overstayed her welcome
come yeah like she was just bringing up
her whole life story where I'm like yeah
picture all this happy with tits out and
[ __ ] out you know she might mean
she's Canadian not too much at once
never felt that a stranger was gonna
murder you when you start talking to
them never I want I did yeah like a
serial way or like a gangster but glad
that I told you at the park
oh yeah talk to him I didn't eat - I
just want the vibe oh thing why are you
gonna sit here right next and I'm like I
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here it could
have been nothing but he looked like he
really wanted to kill my beautiful body
before when Joe said too much talking I
was playing soccer one time again around
18 and
just practicing because I played soccer
that time dude came up he was probably
10 years older hey mind if I kick the
ball around with hammock yeah sure
whatever
Canadian yes he gets talking and then he
says Oh bro back in my place I got it
you play xbox and I'm like not really
anything you want to play I got I got a
we can order pizza whatnot I'm like I'm
good yeah 18 how was this guy probably
like I said 10 years older self
approaching 30 how enthusiastic he was
it's like I've said nothing to indicate
that we have a certain level rapport or
camaraderie
we're just playing songs you won't come
up I got pizza I got Xbox to play xbox
I'll be like I'll bring the weed at $18
really condoms I'll be guys at the park
and they're like oh [ __ ]
you [ __ ] paint alright tonight we're
gonna go paint and it will just go and
really awkward and very low probably
like what how would you approach I'm
still alive today though
self-preservation shouldn't I get it oh
yeah back of your head no I'm trying to
get into that guy yeah yeah I met people
online him like you do do drugs you do a
let's do e okay you won't go to the rave
all right come pick me up
it's so lucky you were in a crime out
maybe you were an ugly ass kid and no
one ever wanted that booty no no other
pictures I was cute I was cute I had a
low self-esteem but I was really cured
[ __ ] hang around you make no mistake
I would have molested me okay no no yeah
I was really I had really nice skin like
I was I was cute right yeah I was a bald
I was smooth yeah okay yeah at that time
I had low self-esteem but then when I
look back I'm like oh oh what a cute kid
I would molest me you were cute back
then I I enjoyed a lot of drugs oh so
you don't even think about it no no I
was just like oh how can I not be in
this world every day escapism yeah cuz
I'm not even thinking about like normal
teen [ __ ] like let's date and like even
though I did have a girlfriend at the
time like I wasn't thinking about it all
the time it was just kind of like
happening well that's not when they said
in this story they said how if you're
happy you can see
if you're sad though it's I'm surprised
it's not mentions like if you're sad
what do you want to do when you're sad
or know I was gonna say bar but some
people like a hookup tinder I'm thinking
of all those things where it's like
actually you like then just a stranger
interaction where that there's a lack of
person ability there's a lack of
closeness so they talked about in the
article to what was it called like
something hedonistic syndrome was that
why people just do like a little bit
more reckless things to Donna Cabana
Connor that one's more like
self-destructiveness might work with
strangers you might hang out with
strangers because you just lonely you
guys start a journal
just like you write journals yeah seeing
her journals I thought oh I brought it
you got a journal what it's so pretty
you share it publicly what you're right
in there no no I show them like the
trackers and stuff but I don't show them
like what I write in there but like I
got stickers on it like this is my cat
my stickers of us yeah I did I gave up
every four valences between a journal or
a diary okay so this is the same [ __ ]
but this all I can you draw tattooed
okay so I have my monthly and then you
drew those cats yeah and I made them
into stickers and then they're stickers
so this is my schedule and then this is
rebel a journal yeah so it's all in one
but then what I'm saying I'm talking
about
you should write I work with jelly on it
okay yeah Joy's not yeah cuz this friend
these are merchandise I might be making
something we don't know but you know
this [ __ ] this habit right is that a
crossword puzzle no it keeps track of
your daily habits so like everything
that you did that day and then other
people have mood trackers too so you can
correlate
like what stuff you got done that day
and then what your mood was that day my
period tracker has a mood track Oh does
it riding into the mood tracker cuz I
feel all the moods every day too many
kind no it's like happy he just took one
mood for the whole day yeah some people
have like they'll do both colors and I
have about two Joseph's drugs should
sound easier laugh and angry I can see
it you're my dad
[Music]